[UPBEAT MUSIC]
RETO MEIER: Hi.
I'm Reto Meier for
"The Developer Show."
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The second annual
TensorFlow Developer Summit
was held on March 30,
and, as you could predict,
it was awesome.
But don't worry if you miss
the event or the livestream.
This post has all
the highlights,
including how we're
making TensorFlow easier
to use, work on more
languages and platforms,
and how we're expanding
the community resources.
"The Dev Show" crew
was also on site
to interview some speakers.
So watch for those
videos coming soon.
D8 is the next
generation dex compiler
that runs faster and
produces smaller dex
files with equivalent or better
run-time performance, when
compared to the
historic compiler.
And D8 is now the
default dex compiler.
To learn more, including
the deprecation plan for DX,
take a look at the post.
The Google Fonts catalog now
includes Korean web fonts
for those of you working with
the Hangul writing system.
To learn more about these fonts
and the Google Fonts API, head
for the post.
Last year, we
introduced MobileNetV1,
a family of general
purpose computer vision
neural networks, designed
for the mobile devices
in mind, to support
classification, detection,
and more.
MobileNetV2 is now available.
And it's a significant
improvement over MobileNetV1,
pushing the state-of-the-art
for mobile visual recognition,
including classification,
object detection,
and semantic segmentation.
Links to the TensorFlow-Slim
image classification library,
collaboratory, Jupyter
Notebook, and GitHub repo
are all in the post.
Cloud Functions
for Firebase helps
you build backend
functionality for your app
without worrying about
managing servers.
Version 1.0 of the Cloud
Functions for Firebase SDK
is now available, with
frequently requested
improvements for the
development, testing,
and monitoring of functions.
More details are in the post.
GitLab and Google Cloud recently
announced a new integration
of GitLab and Kubernetes Engine.
You can now connect your
Kubernetes Engine cluster
to your GitLab
project, and then use
it to run your continuous
integration jobs
and configure a complete,
continuous deployment
pipeline, including previewing
new changes live and deploying
them into production.
Getting started
instructions and screenshots
are all in the post.
Logging and monitoring
are the cornerstones
of network and
security operations.
They let you identify traffic
and access patterns that
might present security
or operational risks
to your organization.
We recently introduced
VPC Flow Logs,
which increase transparency
into your network
and allow you to
track network flows,
all the way down to an
individual virtual interface
in near real time.
A flowchart and screengrab
are in the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Reto Meier for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching.
We'll see you next week.
[POPPING MUSIC]
These are always
such tongue twisters.